après c'est rentré à l'ouest de la
région parisienne voyons maintenant à
l'est de la capitale
l'exemple du quartier de belleville à
paris dans ce quartier et christine
bravo a été institutrice pendant quatre
années
aujourd'hui elle écrit dans la presse
elle vient de publier un livre chez
ramsay un livre maîtresse à belleville
voilà pourquoi nous avons demandé à
christine bravo de retourner sur les
bancs de son école où elle se trouve en
ce moment en compagnie d'al ahmar
comment s'est passée cette rentrée à
belleville ce matin très bien très bien
gérard on pense effectivement qu'il y
aurait peut-être eu des petits problèmes
ici à belleville parce que vous savez
que essentiellement dans cette école il
y à plus de 80% des migraines mais c'est
relativement ça s'est relativement bien
passé donc ce matin nous nous trouvons
ici bien sûr vous l'avez dit parce que
nous avons à nos côtés
christine bravo qui a été donc ici
institutrice qui est maintenant aux
journalistes elle écrit des chroniques
notamment à libération elle vient de
publier le lourd âge que vous avez
montré tout à l'heure et elle est donc
là avec moi pour commenter les images
que nous avons tourné avec les moyens hf
ce matin nous allons d'ailleurs les voir
tout de suite de tout mais rentrer c'est
ma rentrée à belleville qui m'a le plus
marqué
d'abord à cause de ça de l'exotisme des
couleurs des odeurs on s'attend pas être
dépaysés du jour au lendemain en plein
paris bon belleville tout de suite ça a
été la caricature il faut le dire une
liste d'effectifs 30 non impossible à
retenir de préférence moi ça m'a fait
sourire bon je me suis demandé si
j'avais pas été détaché en afrique à mon
insu bon j'insiste là dessus c'est vrai
qu'au début je croyais pas mes yeux
en même temps je reconnaissais les mots
parce qu'ils ont les mêmes lieux les
mêmes services que partout ailleurs
toujours aussi touchants makuch alors
bon ça c'est l'enfer pour les instits
mon les mots même ça mais en général
nous en tant qu'instituteur on se bat
pas pour faire les services c'est vrai
on attend hebdomadaire et aujourd'hui ça
va encore parce que les enfants sont
anesthésiés par l'événement mais après
c'est quand même la cohue le cri et la
course c'est quand même quelque chose de
très stressant le jour de la rentrée et
et après l'appel l'appel c'est aussi
assez dur il faut repérer les noms faire
tenir les enfants tranquilles et les
faire monter une fois qu'on a le compte
alors là aussi ça se passe bien je dire
après c'est
c'est la cohue souvent dans l'année des
embouteillages sur l'escalier
sauf pour les instits à poigne mais là
c'est tout tranquille la rentrée faut
dire que c'est pas le rythme habituel
s'est pas encore usants pour les nerfs
c'est quand même après que ça joue alors
bon là vous les voyez ils sont sages
il tâte le terrain et pacifié et ont en
général on les laisse s'asseoir où ils
veulent et c'est plus facile pour savoir
comme ça à qui on doit séparer à tout
prix lendemain je sais que sadique mais
ce qui est vrai en gros pour moi je sais
pas c'est à peu près comme ça l'année
dernière c'est à dire bien à l'état donc
ça
c'est pas facile mais cette ville que ça
se passe mal chez d'heure voilà le
tableau
calais
gauche
voilà il me semble que vous ayez quand
même vécu ça d'une façon un petit peu
original parce que dans votre bouquin va
dire vous vous en parler de façon très
originale et c'était une expérience qui
a été finalement positive ou pas pour
vous ça a été très positif mais ce qui
est original c'est pas c'est patent
belleville que l'école c'était je veux
dire c'est pas parce que c'était
belleville que ça a était original c'est
parce que c'est original d'avoir raconté
les choses comme ça de cette façon qui a
à ma connaissance ça n'a pas j'ai jamais
lu un ouvrage d'instituteurs écrit de
cette manière mais c'est pas
l'originalité de belleville
effectivement c'est c'est vrai que c'est
exotique et c'est vrai qu'il faut le
dire c'est vrai que c'était la première
fois de ma vie que je me prenais une
liste avec trente noms et 30 noms
étrangers jeudi enfin bon j'exagère en
disant 30 parce qu'en plus j'avais pas
trente enfants dans ma classe les
classes n'ont pas été surchargé ici pas
du tout je veux dire j'ai eu vraiment
une classe avec un petit effectif
non mais justement alors certains
considèrent c'est un enrichissement que
d'avoir des immigrés non dans sa classe
et d'autres que c'est un handicap à laon
pour vous et les péquistes papier c'est
pour moi c'était bien c'était
enrichissant parce que c'était ça
sortait de l'ordinaire et j'en avais
marre justement de de l'ordinaire pour
là c'était quand même c'était un
enrichissement culturel parce que c'est
vrai que j'ai appris des tas de choses
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident quand
on a enseigné avec des repères
chronologiques noël pâques et tout le
monde marche parce que tu sais ce que
c'est la noël bac c'était quand même
c'était l'inconnu c'était et c'était
pour moi le
le grand pardon les machins les trucs
moi je connaissais pas mais bon ça
c'était quand même vous n'avez pas
l'impression quand même que c'est un
petit peu qu'un quai tueur est ce que
vous racontez dans votre se caricaturent
à mai
pas tant que ça parce que ce qui est
caricatural c'est la vie de l'école la
vie de la classe pas tant la vie à
belleville oui je le dis vous parle
également de tabou de choses dont on
parle finalement assez peu vous aviez
des chouchous par exemple j'avais un
chouchou effectivement les instituteurs
n'avoue pas volontiers l'opposition dont
j'avais un chouchou effectivement ils
ont donc tous à la connaissance du mois
parce que je dise que j'ai quand même
discuté avec des instituteurs on ne
reconnaît pas volontiers parce que c'est
vrai ça se fait pas voilà gérard on peut
dire sur cette rentrée à belleville qui
est une rentrée malgré tout relativement
original très bien merci à christine
bravo qui a été maîtresse à belleville
et qui en a fait un livre
merci je signe